في مجله فورين افيرز مقال ناقش بعض
السيناريوهات المحتمله في غزه ما بعد
الحرب استنتج المقال انه يتعين على كل من
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده التخلي عما
سماها الفكره غير الواقعيه المتمثله في
استبعاد حماس للابد من السياسه
الفلسطينيه كما يتعين من جانب اخر تشجيع
ظهور قياده سياسيه موحده يبتعد فيها
الفلسطينيون عن الحسابات السياسيه عدا ذلك
ستظل تسويه الدبلوماسيه بعيده المنال
وستبقى ازمه غزه الانسانيه والامنيه
قائمه جاء في مقال نشرته صحيفتها ارتس ان
اسرائيل تنوي تعميق وتوسيع هجومها على غزه
وسط تراجع الدعم الشعبي للحرب يبرر المقال
تحول مؤشر تاييد الاسرائيليين للحرب على
غزه بغياب هدف واضح لها وغياب مؤشرات الى
امكانيه تحقيق النصر فيها يستعرض المقال
مجموعه من التحديات التي تكتشفها وحدات
الجيش على الارض في غزه ويحذر من مرحله
خطيره تتغير خلالها اراء الجمهور
الاسرائيلي تجاه
الحرب تحدثت الوس جورنال عن جوله
دبلوماسيه جديده يشارك فيها كبار مسؤولي
الاستخبارات والدفاع الامريكيين من اجل
احياء المحادثات بشان اطلاق سراح بقيه
المحتجزين لدى حماس تشير الصحيفه هنا الى
لقاء يجمع مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه بمسؤولين اسرائيليين وقطريين في
وارسو وزياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لاسرائيل لكن الصحيفه ذكرت ايضا ان واشنطن
وجدت نفسها معزوله فيما يتعلق بدبلوماسيه
غزه بسبب دعمها للعمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ورفضها الدعوات المتكرره لوقف
اطلاق النار في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز مقال
يرى ان هناك اسبابا للاعتقاد بان
المحادثات بشان صفقه رهائن جديده ستكون
مثمره منها حادثه مقتل ثلاثه منهم بنيران
القوات الاسرائيليه التي وضعت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تحت مزيد من الضغط يضاف الى
الضغوط التي تمارسها الولايات المتحده
لخفض مستوى العمليات القتاليه والانتقال
الى ما تسميها مرحله جديده من الحرب في
صحيفه الجارديان نقرا عن تعليق عدد من
شركات الشحن الكبرى مرور
عبر البحر الاحمر على خلفيه هجمات
الحوثيين تنقل الصحيفه عن خبير قوله ان
الشركات التي اختار تحويل مسار سفنها تغطي
مجتمعه نحو نصف سوق الشحن عبر العالم
لافتا الى ان تحويل مسار السفن ستترتب
عليه تكاليف اضافيه وتاخير في تسلم
الشحنات